your superhero fan 20:18 already looks
to be an exciting year movies featuring
Black Panther the flash and Aquaman are
all scheduled and there's also a little
movie called Avengers infinity war but
128m release is absolutely guaranteed to
rock your world
Deadpool to the Merc with the mouth is
returning with several fan favorites
from the first movie and the cinematic
debut of some more classic comic book
characters we've got to crisp high 5s
worth of reasons why Deadpool 2 will
blow everyone away ok guys let's get out
there and make a difference you know
what John wick approved if you want to
get someone excited about Deadpool 2 the
only needs used two words John wick
after some behind-the-scenes drama that
caused Deadpool director Tim Miller to
fail on the sequel the project landed
david leitch to take up the job bleach
injected fresh energy into the action
genre whose first John wick taking a
tired revenge premise and building it
into something completely awesome
if Fletch can marry the sleek stylish
action of John wick with the crude
off-the-wall humor of Deadpool will
create a superhero movie like nothing
we've seen or at least a worthy
successor sequel skewering it wouldn't
be Deadpool if it didn't poke fun at
itself and the Deadpool sequel is bound
to go the same way as excited its fans
get about the return of their favorite
heroes and villains too often the
sequels just lack the spark that made
the original so good
fortunately Deadpool 2 is setting out to
put unnecessary super sequels in that
place its producer Simon Kinberg put it
the sort of glut or saturation of these
movies and the proliferation of sequels
is definitely something we'll play
around with even you're reluctant
friends who can't stand each use and the
superhero sequels and reboots might get
a kick out of this phenomenon being
brutally savaged by Deadpool sarcasm
Deadpool and Friends
Deadpool 2 will be expanding its roster
of characters by at least two one will
be Domino a beauty with a very special
ability that can only be described as
good luck when she wants something to
happen she can greatly increase the odds
in the comics she has
run-ins with Deadpool's though their
exact relationship in the upcoming
sequel remains unclear in addition to
potentially bringing Domino to life on
the big screen the movie will also
likely fulfill this promise from the end
of the first one that's equal we're
going to have cable
amazing character bionic arm time travel
in the comics cable had a pretty complex
backstory involving time travel and a
weed techno-organic virus a mash-up of
time paradoxes and clones that any movie
studio would have a hard time
translating to the screen basically a
standalone cable movie ain't gonna
happen
but if Deadpool 2 got ahold of them
cable doesn't have to be anything but a
badass bullet slinging future warrior
the guy we all want to see and be right
at home in dead bulls bonkers cinematic
world look no further than the Deadpool
video game for proof of their perfect
double act this has got to be the
dumbest idea you've ever had
the risk is considerable this is what
gray cable device hello x-force to
casual fan some of these new additions
to the Deadpool sequel may seem a little
random after all a time-traveling cyborg
and Lady Luck seem out of place in the
somewhat grounded reality of Deadpool's
corner of the x-men Cinematic Universe
but with all things Hollywood there are
bigger things on the horizon in the 20th
Century Fox's case that means an export
film in the comics the export was formed
by cables of mutant team that
specialized in wet work fancy way of
saying hacking up bad guys the initial
lineup featured cable is the leader and
Domino is one of his ace soldiers and
now both of these characters are slated
to be in Deadpool 2 and with Ryan
Reynolds reportedly co-writing the
explore script chances are good Deadpool
2 will start laying the foundation for
the x-force returning fabrics it's not
all new names and faces for Deadpool 2
all the best parts of the first movie
are coming back to so far the sequel is
confirmed to feature Deadpool's main
squeeze Vanessa
negasonic teenage warhead colossus and
our favorite taxi driver since Robert
DeNiro
dopinder dopinder this is no way to win
gita's art back
there's also a chance that Vanessa will
play a bigger role in the action in the
comics the character Vanessa is based on
is a mutant with the codename copycat
who has the ability to steal the
appearance and powers of other
characters more likely though Deadpool
is just going to stick the NASA in a
flashy outfit and make a joke about it
yeah that's more wage style more
superhero and mockery the better or
worse were swimming into superhero
movies for this foreseeable future from
Warner Brothers establishing their own
cinematic universe to the unending march
of the MCU it seems like there's always
a cape where door magic hammer hanging
out at your local movie theater one of
those things that may Deadpool so funny
was the way it relentlessly lampooned
these other superhero movies from the
opening credits to Deadpool's breakdown
of angels
superhero landing super ER landing
that's really hard on your knees totally
impractical I'll do it and of course the
meta mockery of Reynolds fails Green
Lantern movie please don't make the
supersuit green or animated one simple
reason to be excited about Deadpool 3 is
that there are so many more movies for
it to make fun of since dead bull we've
seen Logan Captain America Civil War
Batman vs. Superman
Doctor Strange and Suicide Squad and by
the time Deadpool 2 comes out spider-man
homecoming you have been released as
well as guardians of the galaxy vol 2 if
Deadpool is going to pick at superheroes
like we know he will has got plenty of
material to work with discount around
low-budget creativity with all
Deadpool's gorgeous visuals and slo-mo
sarcasm you might be surprised that it
was made with a budget of only 58
million dollars in the world of
superhero cinema we're bloated films
like Batman vs Superman clock in a
budget of 250 million and beyond
Deadpool was essentially made for chump
change this force the creative team to
put an emphasis on characters
relationships and humor Deadpool 2
co-writer Paul Wernick as insisted the
sequel will also be relatively cheap
saying we don't want 150 million dollars
to go make the next movie because that's
not dead dead bull doesn't lift cities
up into the air or battle aliens coming
down to earth taking this interview at
face value it means the sequels
see a continued focus on human
relationships and
charitably low stakes action great news
for those of us who really appreciated
the character-driven original that
amazing trailer if you saw Logan in
theaters you were treated to a doozy of
a Keitha the Deadpool 2 promo that
disguised itself at the beginning of the
Logan movie based on that alone you can
bet Deadpool 2 is going to blow us all
away with references to cables real name
and the best Stan Lee cameo yet Wow
nice suit evidently it's a solid
assurance that the originals violence
humor and self-deprecating humor remain
in force also what's up with that
Firefly poster just a nod to Vanessa
actress Morena Baccarin a jab at Fox for
canceling the show we're Deadpool it
could mean anything or nothing all we
know right now is the Deadpool 2 is
going to be amazing how amazing I'm
touching myself tonight thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all these cool stuff we know
you love to